The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: So
last time, we were
talking about the chiral
Lagrangian as another example
of an effective field
theory to illustrate
some of the tools of
effective field theory
that we didn't meet
when integrating
our heavy particles.
It was an example of a bottom-up
effective field theory.
So we were constructing
it from the bottom
up for the most part.
That's how one should
think about it.
There was several
things in our program
to understand from chiral
perturbation theory.
And we kind of got
halfway through.
So we want to understand
nonlinear symmetry
representations.
And we went through
how you could
think about linear
representations
and making changes of
variable and putting
the Lagrangian in a form
where you could see where
the nonlinear realization was
coming from very explicitly,
as well as another way
where we constructed it
from the bottom up thinking
about parameterizing
the co-set.
And then we started
talking about loops
in chiral perturbation theory.
And I gave you this
example of this loop here.
So we constructed the
chiral Lagrangian.
That's what I've written here.
In terms of the
sigma field, this
is the nonlinear version, sigma
field, exponential of M field.
M field has the
pi n fields in it.
I rewrote it in a little bit
of a different notation, which
will be useful today,
where I introduced
this thing called chi.
But f squared over
8 chi is just Mq.
So it's just a rescaling.
And I just wanted to have
the same kind of pre-factor
here and here.
That's why I did that.
The power counting is in p
squared derivatives or M pi
squared, which is
the same as Mq.
And the reason that M pi
squared and Mq count the same
is there's this relation
between pi squared and the quark
masses.
And then we started
talking about loops.
And we said that, if
we looked at this loop,
the result for this loop diagram
would be a factor of p squared
or M pi squared times
a factor of p squared
or M pi squared
divided by 4 pi f.
This is the same size
as the lowest order,
so the suppression
factor is this.
So we can say that
loops are suppressed
by p squared over some
scale lambda chi squared.
So this is scale
of our expansion.
And we can associate that
scale to 4 pi times f.
OK, so we're going to
continue with that story
unless there's any
questions from last time.
OK, so we want to use
dimensional regularization.
And if we use dimensional
regularization,
we can think about
having an MS bar scheme.
So how do we do that?
It's a little different
than gauge theory,
but the idea is
exactly the same.
So we look at the
dimensions of objects.
This capital M-- supposed
to be a capital M--
is like a scalar field, so it
has dimension 1 minus epsilon.
The decay constant
then, if you look
at it, which is the coupling,
has to have dimension
1 minus epsilon 2.
And you can see that because
this exponential better
be the exponential of
something dimensionless
so that, whatever
the dimension of M,
should cancel the
dimension of f.
And then that works out with
the look with the measure
as well, which has a ddx.
So therefore, just like you
did for a gauge coupling,
you can say f bare in some mu
to the minus epsilon times f.
And if you want to do the same
thing for the second term,
though I've put
the V0 inside the--
sorry, there's something
missing in my equation.
There was a V0 here.
So before last time, we've
written this equation
as V0 out front
and then Mq inside.
And I just rescaled
it to this chi.
OK, so you can think
either in terms of chi.
Chi is kind of absorbing the
parameter along with the Mq,
but they're equivalent things.
So you can think of also
doing a rescaling that
gets the dimension
of this term right.
And the thing that
you want is this.
The P0 would then be mu
to the minus 2 epsilon
to compensate for the fact that
the first term had an f squared
and the second
term just had a V0.
But that's just to
dimension counting.
There's also no mus in physical
quantities like the pi n
mass, which is an
observable, which
has just a definite value.
And there's also, in
chiral perturbation theory,
no mus in the quark mass.
So when you look at
V0 over f squared,
if you look at it bare, that's
the same as renormalized.
The other thing that's different
about this than in a gauge
theory is, in the gauge
theory, you'd have a z.
You'd have g bare is equal
to e to the epsilon times g,
but then you'd have a zg.
But in chiral
perturbation theory,
the way that the
loops work, the loops
aren't renormalizing the
leading order Lagrangian.
The loops are renormalizing
something else
because they ended
up being suppressed.
So you don't need counter-terms
here for the leading order
Lagrangian.
And that's why I didn't
put a zf or a zV0 here.
OK, but when you
do this loop, you
do get ultraviolet divergences.
So you get 1 over
epsilon divergence
if you're using
dimensional regularization.
And it comes along with
the log of mu squared.
And then it'll be
divided by some scale
that you have in your loop, like
an external momentum p squared,
or it could be the pi n mass.
Both of those will
show up generically.
And in the way we're doing
counting, the way the loops are
showing up, if I can bind
together the factors that I
told you about here, it's either
p to the fourth, 4 powers of p,
or 2 of p and 2 of M
pi or 4 powers of M pi.
So to cancel that
1 over epsilon,
we need a counter-term.
But it's not a counter-term
in that Lagrangian.
It's a counter term in the
higher order Lagrangian.
So we're not done by just
calculating the loop.
We have to actually include
some higher dimension
operators that are the same
order in our power counting.
So we'll talk about
SU(3) a little later.
I'll start out by
talking about SU(2).
In SU(2), the form of that
Lagrangian with higher order
terms is just taking what
we had before and just
going to a higher dimension.
So we could have two
more derivatives.
One way of doing that is taking
what we had at lowest order
and squaring it.
Another way of doing it
would be to take and contract
the indices a little
bit differently.
So I could do it like this.
The trace is cyclic, so I can
move things around from back
to front.
But I could have
mu nu in one trace
and mu nu in another trace
rather than just contracting
within the trace.
That's another possible term.
And there's a bunch
more terms which
I decided to wait and enumerate
when we do SU(3) to give you
a full enumeration.
These additional
terms you can build
from one Mq, which means one
of these chi fields or chi
objects and two partials.
That's one possibility or
two Mq's because each Mq
counts like two derivatives.
So there's some other
terms that we could build
that are analogs of this term.
You could square that
term, for example.
That would be a possible
higher order term.
And so these coefficients
of this Lagrangian
are what we need to cancel
off the divergences.
So the counter-terms
that we have
that renormalize
these loop graphs
come from this Lagrangian.
So the theory is renormalizable
in a EFT sense, order
by order in its power
counting expansion.
When you go to order
p to the fourth,
you have to consistently
put in everything
that's order p to the fourth.
That includes the loops,
which are p to the fourth,
as well as new local
Lagrangian interactions.
AUDIENCE: Is that a
choice to not renormalize
the f bare and [? d ?] bare?
IAIN STEWART: They just
don't get renormalized.
AUDIENCE: But why couldn't
I just multiply by 1 plus--
IAIN STEWART: Oh--
AUDIENCE: --order p squared
by times delta [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: Oh, you
want to try to make
a different scheme for them?
AUDIENCE: I'd screw up the
power counting [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: So
effectively, you
could screw up the power
counting by doing that.
So let me tell you
what you can do.
You could put a 2 here, right?
But you don't really
have much more freedom
than just multiplying
by a number.
AUDIENCE: So I can't
multiply by 1 plus
p squared over s squared.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
That would be a screwing
up the power counting.
And effectively, you wouldn't
be multiplying by p squared.
You'd be putting
derivatives in, right?
Because there's no p.
So p is not something that
you're allowed to multiply by.
AUDIENCE: So that's
the only thing
that's stopping me-- is what
is derivatives [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: You could
put derivatives in,
but then that's equivalent
to something here.
So you have to ask what you're
doing because you're mixing up
things.
AUDIENCE: OK.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
definitely a better way to do.
I was just wondering if
there was sort of freedom.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
there's no freedom really.
AUDIENCE: Good.
AUDIENCE: Why you don't get the
renormalization [INAUDIBLE],,
like from [INAUDIBLE]
[? loop? ?]
IAIN STEWART: Because all the
loops end up being suppressed
by p squared or M pi squared.
So if you write down any diagram
and you think it might give
something here, even if
it's a two-point function,
it just doesn't.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
to 4 [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: That's right.
Oh, so if you want, you could
think that some terms here
are kind of corrections
to the kinetic term
if you derive the
equation of motion
and you include L and that L
and this L. But this Lagrangian,
there's no loop corrections
to this Lagrangian.
There's no corrections to
this lowest order Lagrangian.
And that's because the
loops are all suppressed.
Totally different
then gauge theory,
loops are suppressed by p
squared or M pi squared.
So they only renormalize
some high order things.
And we don't have to worry
about really thinking about f.
I mean, the way I've
talked about f here
and the factors of
mu is just in order
to see where these factors
and mu come out here.
But what actually happens is
that you get 1 over epsilons
that are cancelled like
the counter-terms here.
And there's no need from a
renormalization perspective
to sort of change
your definitions here.
People play with
different definitions,
but it's like they
use f squared over 4
instead of f squared over 8.
That's the extent
of what people do
with playing with the
leading order Lagrangian.
AUDIENCE: So you have
[INAUDIBLE] the same thing with
the [INAUDIBLE] that
[INAUDIBLE] [? is not ?]
[? renormalizing ?] [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: Both of
them are not, yeah.
Yeah.
So loops that you build
out of these interactions
end up renormalizing these
terms, which is kind of neat.
AUDIENCE: That's just
because [INAUDIBLE]..
That's just because there's
[INAUDIBLE] [? sort of ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
Well, so we'll prove in a
minute a general power counting
formula that tells us
how to organize all this.
So for now, you can think
of it as an observation,
but we'll build it into a
general formula that tells you
sort of how you would
organize the power counting
and renormalization
of this theory
to all orders in its
expansion in a minute.
AUDIENCE: So when you write
down all these [INAUDIBLE]
at [? power ?] [? p4, ?]
does that include all
the [INAUDIBLE] you need?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
That's right.
Once I've enumerated
all the terms,
which I will do for
you with SU(3)--
so it includes things like this
and things like this as well--
then those are all the
possible counter-terms
that you could actually
need to renormalize
any of the one-loop
diagrams that you
could generate with the
leading order Lagrangian.
And you know that
by power counting.
Once you know the
loops are that order
and you've included all local
interactions, then you're done.
So there's things I didn't
write down there, so just
comment about that.
So what is the equation
of motion here?
It's a little more complicated
because we have the sigma
field, but you can work out
that the equation of motion
is the following.
And I've given you
some reading, so you
can read about a derivation
of this equation which
takes a little effort.
So your leading order
equation of motion
basically allows you to
get rid of partial squareds
on the sigma.
And that's why
I've always written
one partial on each sigma.
So that's what you should
think of this guy doing.
There's also some
SU(2) identities
that have been used, even
in what I've written,
because you could think of
having other types of traces
like this one, for example.
Instead of having trace squared,
I could have the following.
Just put everything
in one trace.
I always have to alternate
sigma sigma dagger,
sigma sigma dagger because del
mu sigma sigma dagger is 0.
Because sigma sigma dagger is 1.
And that provides an identity
that I'm also able to use.
And so I want to
have sigmas and sigma
daggers next to each other.
Sorry, chiral symmetry means
that sigmas and sigma daggers
should be next to each other.
This is an identity that I can
also use to simplify things.
So that allows me to
move things around.
And this operator,
though, in SU(2)
is actually related
to these two.
It's not unique.
Because of the structure
of Pauli matrices,
you have a formula
which you can work out,
which says that
this guy is actually
half of the trace squared.
And there's another
one if you did.
This guy, he also can be related
to those two guys over there.
So there's a bunch
of things that
went into even writing down
the level of information
that I told you.
You could think
there's more things,
but then, when you enumerate
all the possible things
that you can do, you find
that those more things
are related to these things.
So you really want to
construct a minimal basis.
And there's some things
that go into doing that.
So at order p to the fourth, as
I said, we include both loops.
And those loops will have
terms like p to the fourth log
mu squared over p squared.
And we include terms
like the L1 and L2,
which are p of the
fourth type interactions.
Once I take out
the counter-term,
the renormalized coupling
is mu dependent just
like the gauge coupling.
This just comes from a
four-point interaction
with the Li.
And the mu dependence,
by construction,
was canceled between
these two things.
The divergence from the loop is
cancelled by the counter-term.
And correspondingly, the
corresponding statement,
if you want to make
it in terms of mu,
is that the mu dependence that
is tightly tied to that 1 over
epsilon is cancelled in the
renormalized quantities.
So there's these
two contributions.
They're both mu dependent.
And that mu dependence cancels.
So the way that you
should think of this
is you should think
mu is a cut off.
It's not a hard cut off,
but it is a cut off.
And what the cut off
is doing is dividing up
infrared and
ultraviolet physics.
In this case, the
low energy physics
is in the matrix
elements in the loops
where we have our propagating
low energy degrees of freedom,
which are the pions.
And the high energy physics is
in the coefficients, as usual.
And they're both mu dependent.
And you can think of that
mu dependent as a cut off
that divides up how
much of the physics
goes into those low energy
loops, how much of the physics
goes into the couplings.
So the difference between
this and integrating
on a massive particle
is not the physics
of where things go because
the low energy physics always
goes in the matrix elements.
The high energy physics
goes in the couplings.
The difference is that, here,
the way that you should think
of it is that we can calculate
the matrix elements explicitly
because our theory is in terms
of the right degrees of freedom
to describe long distance
physics, which are the pions.
And then the coefficients
are the unknowns.
That's the way in
which it's different.
And that's really
kind of the difference
between bottom-up and top-down.
So with that in
mind, if you want
to think of what these
couplings are, if we just
divide by f squared, then you
can think about dimensionally
what they are.
In order for them
to sort of match up
with what we got
from the loops is
that they have some dependence
that looks like this.
You can think of
it as parameterized
by some coefficients a and b.
If I want to match up with the
4 pi f squared that comes from
the loops, then I have to sort
of say that there's a 4 pi
hiding inside the Li's.
So I can do that.
And then there's some
coefficients here.
There's some mu dependence.
And the scales that
are in the coefficients
are the high scales, like
lambda chi and higher
and rho, those types of things.
So let me just
call it lambda chi.
And then there's
some numbers here a
and b, which encode
the high mass physics.
Now, the point of thinking
about power counting
is that thinking about
the fact that the loops
and these coefficients
are the same size
actually tells you that
these ai's and bi's should
be order 1.
And this actually goes under
the rubric of something called
naive dimensional analysis.
So what naive
dimensional analysis says
is that this cut off that we've
put between the low energy
physics and the high energy
physics is arbitrary.
And we could change it.
We could change it
by a factor of 2.
And what changing it does is
it moves pieces back and forth.
But if we could move
pieces back and forth,
then you wouldn't expect that
the two things that you're
talking about would be
different in magnitude
because we're allowed to
move pieces back and forth.
So you expect that the
size of contributions
from the coefficients are about
the same size as the loops.
And that's this naive
dimensional analysis.
So changing mu moves
pieces back and forth.
The sum is mu independent, but
each individual thing is not.
And because we're able to
move things back and forth,
we expect them to be the
same order of magnitude.
And that is this statement
here, that the ai's and bi's,
once I account for the 4 pis--
so with this argument,
I can figure out
where there's 4 pis hiding
in the coefficients.
Because I can identify
4 pis in loops.
And then if they're supposed
to be the same size,
I can also identify 4
pis in coefficients.
So if you had figured this out,
I don't know, 20 years ago,
then you could have got a PhD
thesis like Aneesh Manohar did,
which was 25 pages long.
Short PhD theses do exist.
OK.
So what do we do in practice?
In practice, we have
to pick a value of mu.
Just like when we were
talking about gauge theory,
we need to pick a value of mu.
There we were picking
things like mu equals Mb.
Here, what people do
is they typically pick
mus that are high.
So maybe they would
pick the rho mass.
Maybe they would
pick lambda chi.
Or they pick just something
in between, like a GeV.
These are typical
values that people use.
So what that means is that
you've removed all large logs
from your coefficients.
And that's because you
want dimensional analysis
to hold for your coefficients
because you don't know them.
So you would like to
have some power counting
estimate for them.
Then you'd like to go
out and fit them to data.
And you'd like the result
that you get from fitting
to the data to agree with
your power counting estimate,
so that you're happy.
It turns out that it
does, so you are happy.
And so to avoid large
logs in the story,
you put the large logs
into the matrix elements.
So that's different than our
story in gauge theory, where
we were thinking that we would
re-sum all the large logarithms
in the coefficients.
And then our matrix
elements would also
have no large logarithms.
Here, we're just
saying, well, let's
allow for large logs
in the matrix element.
But the story is also
different from gauge theory
in another way, which
is that there's not
an infinite series here
of large logarithms
that you need to re-sum.
And that's related to the fact
that the kinetic term didn't
get renormalized.
There's no mu dependence
in the coefficients
of the kinetic term.
So when the loop
graphs aren't having
coefficient squared depending
on mu, that doesn't happen.
We simply have one log
in our loop graphs,
one log from our
counter-term diagrams.
They explicitly cancel.
There's no high order terms.
The renormalization group
here is completely trivial.
If you integrate,
you just get one log.
So there's not really even
a reason to talk about it.
OK, so there's certainly some
differences in this theory
than there are in gauge theory.
And so typically, the
paradigm that you have is you
can calculate matrix elements.
You're going to fit
the coefficients.
You think of enough
experiments such
that you can get
all that information
about those coefficients.
And then you can think
of other experiments
and make predictions.
Now, as you go to higher
orders in the theory,
you get more
coefficients because you
keep having to go
to higher orders
and construct higher
dimension operators.
And so the paradigm of figuring
out how to fit the coefficients
gets harder and harder.
And at some point,
you effectively
lose predictive
power because you
can't think of enough
observables that
can be measured in order to
fit all your coefficients.
But certainly, at
order p to the fourth,
people can think of
many more observables.
And actually, people
have worked out p
to the sixth as well here.
So two-loop chiral
perturbation theory
is kind of the state of the art.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So why allow log in
this case [? is not ?] screwing
up the [INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
It doesn't screw it up
because it only happens once.
So basically, what you
could say is you can say,
I have this matrix element.
It's got a large log
and a coefficient.
The coupling, it's not
like large log times
the coupling is something that
you could count as order 1
because that's not
going to reappear
in the higher order when
you go to the higher order.
So you still have a large log.
And you are allowed to
say that large log is
the most important piece
of my matrix element,
but it doesn't repeat
itself in the higher orders.
Because once you
go to higher loops,
you're actually
getting something
that's power suppressed,
not loop suppressed.
So the loops are giving
power suppression.
And that changes
a lot of things.
OK.
What would happen if
we used a hard cut off?
Maybe some of this story would
be a bit more transparent
if we'd done that because we'd
see that we were explicitly
dividing up low energy
and high energy physics.
But there's a price to
pay for that transparency.
And here, effectively
everybody decides
it's too high a price to pay.
And so they use dim reg.
So what type of
prices would you pay?
So if you did that,
this loop here
would actually
have terms that are
cut-off to the fourth over
lambda chi to the fourth.
And that guy breaks
chiral symmetry.
I mean, it's giving
a constant term.
And you're not seeing
the derivative coupling.
And that means, effectively,
that there's no counter-term
to absorb this
dependence in our L chi
because our L chi
respected chiral symmetry.
So that's kind of bad.
If you had a cut-off,
you'd also get
terms that went cut-off
squared times momentum squared
where two powers of the p
are replaced by cut-off.
And that, in this language
that we used earlier,
would break the power
counting in the sense
that we have a
power counting that
says that the loops should be
suppressed by d to the fourth.
And it's broken by this.
And then you would need to
absorb that and renormalize
you're leading order coupling.
But effectively, all
the renormalization
would be doing is restoring
your power counting.
It's not doing something
that you should interpret
as really a physical thing.
So it's just something
to be avoided.
And then finally, the physics
that you actually want,
which is the logs of the
cut-off, would also be there.
And you would do the same
thing as you do in dim reg.
You would absorb that in
higher dimension operators, OK?
So we won't use a
cut-off because we
don't want to think
about things that
are breaking power counting
or messing up chiral symmetry.
Another thing that's different
about chiral theories
versus gauge theories
is the structure
of infrared divergences.
And that's because you
have derivative couplings.
So you have many fewer
infrared singularities
than you have in gauge theory.
And in fact, you
usually don't have any.
And one way of describing
that is that you usually
have a good M pi
squared goes to 0
or p squared goes to 0
limit of your results.
So you can just explicitly
take these limits
and talk about the
results in those limits.
And if we look back at
what we were talking about,
you get p to the
fourth log p squared.
So there's a p to the fourth
multiplying the log p squared.
So you're not seeing
log p squared blow up
because it's got so many
powers of p multiplying it.
Although our focus
is on formalism,
I have to at least give you one
example of something predictive
and phenomenological.
So pi pi scattering is a nice
example of phenomenology.
And it's particularly
nice if you look at it
below an elastic threshold.
So you just have
elastic scattering.
So you could look at
pi pi goes to 4 pi.
And that's something
you could actually
look at in chiral
perturbation theory.
But if we look at just
pi pi goes to pi pi
where we have not enough
energy to produce 4 pions,
then the scattering is
particularly simple.
It's just described by
an S matrix, which we can
enumerate channel by channel.
And it's just a phase where
this L is a partial wave phase.
And the i is an isospin.
So for each isospin and for
each angular momentum state,
we get different phases.
But that's encoding
all the scattering.
That's like doing
non-relativistic scattering
or very simple quantum
mechanical scattering.
And when you have an elastic
scattering like that,
there's something called the
effective range expansion,
which is a derivative expansion
for the phase shift delta.
And if you do it for an
arbitrary partial wave,
this is how it looks.
So this is, again,
something that you
would find in the discussion
of scattering theory in quantum
mechanics.
And you have a
derivative expansion
of this quantity p to
the 2L plus 1 cotan
of that phase shift.
And the a's here and the
r0 depend on what channel
you're talking about.
And if we actually just
take the fact that we can--
so this is a description
from quantum mechanics.
This is true irrespective
of what theory
you're talking about as
long as you don't have
other channels you can produce.
If you talk about it from
chiral perturbation theory,
though, we can just calculate
pi pi goes to pi pi.
And if you do that,
which [? Weinberg ?] did,
then you just get results
for these coefficients.
So I'll just quote a
couple of them to you.
So you just get
parameter-free results,
parameter-free in the
sense that they just
involve M pi and this thing f.
This thing f is actually
measured by pi on decay,
so it's not an unknown.
And then from that,
at lowest order
in chiral perturbation
theory, you
have no parameters once
you fixed M pi and f pi.
And you can just
make predictions
for these scattering lengths,
and those are the predictions.
And they're parameter-free in
the sense that I just said.
OK, so that gives
you some of the idea
of what chiral perturbation
theory can do for you.
OK, so let's talk about
back to formalism.
There's many more
phenomenological examples
you could do, but
that's not our focus.
Back to formalism and
back to this general power
counting discussion, so let's
consider an arbitrary diagram
in this theory, this
chiral perturbation theory.
And let's enumerate some
pieces of that diagram.
So we'll say that it has
some number of vertices.
We just count how
many times I've
inserted vertices
from the Lagrangians,
and I'll call that NV.
Some number of internal lines--
call NI.
Some number of external lines--
the external lines
are all pions.
That's what our
theory is describing.
It could be kaons and etas
if we're doing SU(3)--
and. then some number of loops.
So we have an integer associated
with each of these things.
And when I talk
about vertices, I
don't want to restrict myself
just to the leading order
vertices.
I want to talk about also
these Li's and higher order
vertices as well.
So let me have a notation for
that, where I take this integer
NV, which counts all
vertices, and split it
into pieces that count
the vertices at each
of those different orders
in the expansion in p.
So Nn is the number
of vertices that
are order p to the n or M pi
to the n or combinations of p
and M pi to the n, but
n of them, all right?
So hopefully, that's clear.
So if I have two insertions
of the leading order
Lagrangian and one insertion
of the sub-leading,
then n sub 0 would be 2.
And N sub 1 would be 1.
And the total would be 3.
That's what this notation means.
So we'll assume we're
using a regulator
like dimensional regularization.
So we don't have to worry
about the regulator messing up
power counting.
And basically,
that means we could
ignore the regulator as far as
this discussion is concerned.
And we just count.
And effectively, we can
just count mass dimension.
So we'll count
lambda chi factors.
Let's think about it that way.
And we'll think about counting
lambda chi factors for a matrix
element that I'll call curly
M, which has NE external pions.
So NE lines are
poking out of it.
So then if we look
at the vertices,
we can count how many factors
of lambda chi there is.
And I'm counting
all dimensionful
and turning all dimensionful
things into lambda chi.
And so each different order in
N gets a number of lambda chis
because we even saw that
already in the examples
we treated where we got f
squared from the leading order.
But from the
sub-leading, we got Li.
And that was dimensionless.
So for n equals 2, which
is the leading order here,
leading order was p squared.
I said that not quite
right a minute ago.
So lowest order is p
squared n equals 2.
That's L0.
That had an f squared.
And that comes out, if I just
have 4 minus 2, that's 2.
n equals 4, that was giving our
Li's, which were dimensionless,
OK?
So you can see the
formula working.
And if we went to higher orders
in the derivative and chiral
expansion, then we'd
start getting lambda chis
in the denominator.
So this is just counting
from the vertices, which
you should think
of as counting just
from the pre-factors
in the Lagrangian.
There's also f's that
come with the pions
because every factor of the pion
field comes with a factor of f.
You always have pi over f.
And I'm turning f into 4
pi f for this discussion.
I'm not worrying
about the 4 pis.
You could do a
more fancy version
of this where you
worry about the 4 pis,
but let's just focus
on the dimensions.
So if you have an
internal line, that's
a contraction of 2 pion fields.
So that gets 2f's.
And the external line
is just 1 pion field,
so that just gets 1.
Topologically, these different
things that we enumerated
are not unrelated.
So the order identity
tells us that the number
of internal lines is
the number of loops
plus the number of
vertices minus 1.
And so we use that
to get rid of NI.
So then we can just put
these things together.
So if I get rid of NI here
and I replace it by NL--
so that's that term--
I replace it by the sum over
the Nn's which are the vertices.
And then this gives me a plus 2.
OK.
Now, that's not the dimension
of the left-hand side.
That's just the dimension
of the ingredients.
There's also things that are
coming from factors of M pi
or factors of p.
And let me just call that
something, E to the D
where D is just some
number, integer,
and then some function of
logarithms of p over mu
or M pi over mu.
So E could be M pi or p.
And for the purpose
of power counting,
I'm not distinguishing.
So let's just call it E
just to have a notation that
could be either M pi or p.
And then there's one
more thing we can do,
which is we can look
at the left-hand side.
And we can say, just by
dimensional analysis,
the matrix element, what
should be its dimension?
And depending on how many
bosons you have sticking out,
your matrix element should
have a certain dimension,
which you could figure out.
And that dimension
is just 4 minus NE.
Two-point function would scale
like p squared, et cetera.
So now, I have different
things that are giving mass
dimensions, the lambda
chis and the E's.
But because I know what the
answer has to be, 4 minus NE,
I can solve for D.
And that's what I got.
OK.
So the answer for D, in order
to get the dimensions right,
we have to compensate for
the number of lambda chis
by factors of M pi and p.
And when we do that, then
we need this many of them
in order to get the
dimensions right.
So one thing you see
from this formula
is that D is greater
than or equal to 2.
That's because these
things are positive.
The Lagrangian starts with n
equals 2 and then goes higher.
And when I add either of these
terms, I cause suppression,
or I stay the same.
So this could be 0.
This could be 0, or
it could be bigger.
But it can be smaller.
So you always get
more E's, which
are M pis or p's, by adding
vertices or adding loops.
So when you looked at the loop
graphs that were built out
of the leading order
Lagrangian, those terms
had this be 0 because n was 2.
But then you got suppression
because we built loop graphs.
So you got suppression
from this term.
And when we looked at the
higher dimensional operators,
there was no loop.
So we didn't have
this term, but then we
had a contribution
from this guy.
But those were trading off.
So having this is,
effectively, part
of what we need in order to make
sure the theory is well-defined
because it tells us how
to organize the theory
and what parts of
the theory we need
to worry about if we
want a certain accuracy
and what parts we can ignore.
We need to know that
we don't need to think
about two-loop diagrams.
And this tells us that we don't.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I didn't understand
[? where you ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
let me say it again.
So we figured out the lambda
chis by this stuff up here.
Then I said, let
there be an arbitrary
E to the D, some
parameter which we haven't
figured out anything yet.
But I know by just
what possibly this
could depend on that it could
also depend on an M pis or pis.
So let me put some polynomial
power in and then some function
that could be non-polynomial.
AUDIENCE: But where
would that-- can you
give an example of a
calculation where I
would see exactly what that is?
IAIN STEWART:
Yeah, so if you did
this loop calculation
we did a minute ago,
we got a p to the fourth.
And then D would be 4.
AUDIENCE: And those
p's came from where?
IAIN STEWART: Oh, they came
from the momentum going--
so if you looked
at this diagram,
there's p coming in here.
And then it goes
into the loop, right?
And this is
derivatively coupled,
so you get p's in the numerator.
AUDIENCE: But that wasn't
taken care of with [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: Right.
Because NV is just
counting lambda chis,
which are constants,
not the p's.
It's just counting the
constants, the f's.
AUDIENCE: OK.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
And then you equate it to this,
and then you get the D. Yeah.
So you could have
tried to set things up
by thinking about counting p's
instead of counting lambdas.
But it's-- yeah, anyway.
All right, so what people
often refer to this
is they say it's p
counting because you're
counting momenta.
And that includes p or M
pi, but sometimes people
call it p counting.
And just to do some examples,
when we had the lowest order
Lagrangian, this guy
comes out as 2 powers of p
because there's two derivatives.
And that, in our
formula, is just the fact
that D is 2 for that.
When we thought about this loop
with leading order Lagrangians,
which are scaling
like p squared,
we ended up having D equals 4.
And the way that that
comes out of the formula
is because of this
loop term, which is 1.
And then there's 2 plus 2 is 4.
And this guy is 4 because
of the explicit suppression.
OK.
So the theory is organized
as an expansion of this p.
All right, so I
want to come back
to SU(3) partly
because the problem
that I gave you is in SU(3).
So we'll do some discussion
of the SU(3) case.
I'll go into a few things
in a little more detail
than we did for
SU(2), where we were
focusing on more formal things.
So SU(3) would have gamma
matrices instead of the Pauli
matrices.
There's two bases
that you can use.
You can either use
this basis, which
is like enumerated
1 to 8, or you
could use the charged basis.
And if you use
the charge basis--
and often you write it
out as a matrix like this.
On your problem set, you're
free to pick which basis
you want to use.
It may be that one or
the other is easier,
but I can't even tell
you which one is easier
since I don't remember.
So sometimes one or the
other is easier to use.
And you have a freedom
of what basis to pick.
If you expand, in this case,
the trace of sigma Mq dagger
plus Mq sigma dagger, which
is that term that had a V0,
then that gives
mass to the mesons,
as it did for the pions.
Because the symmetry
group is bigger,
you get more predictions.
Here, you get predictions
for the kaon masses.
And you get things like the
fact that the neutral kaons have
massless order Md plus
Ms. And you get things
like eta pi 0 mixing, where
there's a mixing matrix.
So if you look at the
masses of eta and pi 0,
they're actually non-diagonal.
So for the eta in
the pi 0 system,
you actually get a matrix.
So M squared is a matrix.
So for example, for the pi
0, it was just M up plus Md.
But then once you're in SU(3),
there's actually a mixing term.
And there's like an M up
minus M down term here
that is mixing between, and
then same thing over here.
So the etas and the pi
0s actually are mixing.
And there's something
in this n tree.
And the mixing is isospin
violating in the sense
that it's M up minus M down.
So it's a small effect,
but this is something
that you can predict from
chiral Lagrangian, something
about because is describes
isospin violating effects
from the quark masses.
So the reason that
I mention that is
because, often when you
do calculations, keeping
track of Mu's,
Md's, and Ms's all
as separate independent
parameters is a little much.
And so you want to
make an approximation.
And so if you make
an approximation that
ignores isospin violation--
so we often ignore
isospin violation.
Isospin violation is very small.
And if you remember,
for the SU(3) case,
you're expanding in Ms
over lambda QCD or Mk
over lambda chi.
So it's not a great expansion.
You have something like a third.
So ignoring isospin
is perfectly valid
if you're expanding in a third.
So basically, because
there is a hierarchy
between the strange quark
mass and the down and the up,
you want to focus on places
where you get the largest
corrections.
And one way of making
an approximation that
allows you to do that is
to ignore isospin and take
Mu equal to Md.
So if we take Mu at
Md to be some M hat--
which if you want an exact
definition, you could say
it's the average.
And you'd drop the difference.
And then you can think
of the strange quark mass
as being somewhat
bigger than M hat.
That's an approximation that
you can use on your problem set,
for example.
So let me write out
here with all the terms
in the chiral Lagrangian is.
And I'll do it for
a case where we
include in our chiral Lagrangian
one other type of coupling,
which is this left-handed
current that we
talked about last time.
So we talked about a spurion
analysis for the chi term.
And I said you
could do something
similar to a couple in
a left-handed current.
And we had this,
where D mu sigma
was partial mu sigma times
the left-handed current sigma.
So we thought of
putting it together
into a coherent derivative.
And if I do that, it modifies
the leading order Lagrangian
and just makes these partials
into covariant derivatives.
Power counting, for
counting purposes,
you count sigmas of order 1.
You count D mu sigma as order
p, which means you count
L mu, the source, as order p.
This is a left-handed source.
And you count chis and
Mq's as of order p squared.
That's just repeating
what we've already said.
And these higher order
terms, which where L's, we
can then enumerate.
And I now just use
D's, covariant D's
when I write them down.
I'm now in SU(3).
And it turns out that one of the
relations that we used in SU(2)
doesn't carry over to SU(3).
So if I just think of guys with
four covariant derivatives,
it turns out that there's
one more operator there.
So there's those two, which
we talked about, L1 and L2.
And then there's also L3.
So we can't get rid of this guy.
I'm always writing sigmas
next to sigma daggers because
of the chiral transformation.
I'm also imposing
parity, though I'm not
going to spend much
time talking about that.
And really I want to
enumerate, also, for you
some of the terms that involve
the quark mass, the chi guy.
So you could have a guy
that's a cross-term.
This would take care of the
renormalization of things
like p squared and pi
squared times 1 of epsilon.
That's L4, L5.
We could also have the quark
mass type term just squared.
So take the trace and square it.
That's L6.
It turns out that we
could also build something
with the right parity by just
having the difference instead
of the sum.
And that's a different operator.
So that's L7.
We're going to go up to 9.
Don't be afraid.
You can have something
with 2 sigma daggers
and 2 chis, which is another way
of building a chiral invariant.
And then for parity,
you need the other way.
And then finally--
something called
L9, which involves a
trace that involves
L mu nu, where L mu nu is built
out of this external current.
So we can take two of
our covariant derivatives
and take a commutator.
That's giving the
final operator.
So there's a complete basis for
SU(3) for a left-handed current
in the chi.
AUDIENCE: [? So does ?]
[? L mu ?] [? nu ?]
[? have a field ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[? associated with ?]
[INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
I'll write it down.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
IAIN STEWART: So if
L mu is something
that has SU(3) indices, has an
SU(3) matrix hiding inside it,
then there's a
commutator term as well.
And then it's just
this combination.
I also use the
equation of motion.
And I didn't talk about it, but
I use the equation of motion.
And I used SU(3) relations.
Much as I talked
about for SU(2),
there's some SU(3)
relations that survive.
And I got rid of some
operators doing that.
Now, you could say, well, I
have this SU(3) and SU(2),
so why don't I try
to relate them?
One of them has a kaon.
The other one doesn't.
The one without the kaon
thinks about the kaon
as a heavy particle.
The one with the kaon
thinks about the kaon
as a light particle.
Those are two theories.
I could try to make them
match up with each other.
And that's something that
you can do, actually.
So there's a little
bit of a lesson there.
So that was why I
want to mention it.
So SU(2) and SU(3)
seem like they're
describing similar physics.
They both could describe pions.
They both have pions in them.
But the SU(3) has more.
It's got the kaon.
That means that, in
the SU(2) theory,
the kaon is in the
coefficients, OK?
So if you do a
correspondence, you
get relations that
are like this.
So the 2 here means SU(2).
And where I don't put any
subscript, it's SU(3).
And something
that-- this is a 96.
And if you really do that, what
I said, compare observables,
you get relations like
this one where you actually
see the kaon is
showing up on this side
and is being encoded in
coefficients in the SU(2)
theory.
So what you think of
as the coefficients
in your chiral theory
depends on the matter
that you've put in,
including things
like what particles like
the kaon, what group you're
talking about.
This is an explicit example of
the kaon being the coefficients
if we use SU(2).
OK, so just like in SU(2),
we have to go through
a renormalization of the Li's.
And you can think of
that by writing a formula
like this one.
Bare Li is equal to
some renormalized one,
which I put a bar on top
of and then a counter-term.
And the counter-term
will be some coefficient,
some number of 4 pis,
and then some epsilons.
And just like in
gauge theory, we
get rid of the Euler
gamma and the log 4 pi.
We have an Ms bar
type definition.
And in chiral
perturbation theory,
people often take an extra
1 along with the ride
just because they're allowed to.
Because it tends to show
up in the kind of loops
that you encounter.
So sometimes that's
included, sometimes it's not.
So for example, as an
example of a diagram,
you could think about this one.
And that does cause
mass renormalization
for the physical boson.
So if you think about
our lowest order relation
as where we started, let me
write that as M0 squared is
4V0 over f squared Mu plus Md.
Sometimes people call this--
well, making up
some more notation,
yeah, which I'll
use in a minute.
And so if you actually
calculate this loop,
then you get a correction
to that formula.
This would have be M pi squared,
but here we get a correction.
If you did it in
SU(2), just to keep
the formula a little simpler,
then it would look like this.
So M0 is like the pi n mass, but
the pi n mass at lowest order
in the chiral expansion.
So it's not the
physical pi n mass.
So 2L 4 bar in theory two with
two flavors with two SU(2) plus
an L5 bar minus 4 n L6 bar--
so these various
coefficients are coming in
with some numbers in front,
some combination of them.
And then there's
some contribution
from a chiral loop.
And if I take away that 1,
it's just a chiral logarithm.
So this is 4 pi f squared log
M0 squared over mu squared.
There would be an extra term
of just plus 1 times this
if I hadn't gotten rid of that,
the minus 1 times that, OK?
So this is from the loop.
This is from the explicit
dimension operators
that were of the higher
dimension, some combination
of them.
The UV divergence is absorbed
in some combination of them.
And if you want to figure out
exactly how UV divergences go
in between this, then you've
got to think of renormalizing
more than just this diagram.
And you can generically
think of observables
as having this kind of
expansion in Mu and Md.
So if you like, you should think
of M0 here as really just an up
plus M down.
This is saying, at lowest order
chiral perturbation theory,
there's a linear term.
But then here there's an M0
to the fourth term, which is
quadratic in the quark masses.
And there's also a quadratic
term from the loops.
So you have an expansion
in the quark masses.
Think of M0 as the quark masses
and M pi as the meson mass.
I just gave you the
example of the pion mass,
but this is generically
true for observables
that you might calculate that
they have this type of result
where you have an expansion.
AUDIENCE: Is there any physical
reason for why this mass square
of the meson space [? would ?]
[? be ?] [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: So one
way of saying it is--
yeah.
So you might think, well, why
is it not M pi equals Mu and Md?
And the glib way of
saying it is, well,
if you think about
M pi squared and you
think about it
having an expansion,
then it could have a
constant plus linear term
plus quadratic term.
You don't have the constant
because of the chiral symmetry.
So the linear term is the
first thing that's allowed.
That's one way of saying it.
I mean, if you think about
it in the bosonic theory,
we have the Lagrangian
is quadratic in masses,
right, whereas in
the fermionic theory,
you have linear in masses.
And that's also part of
what it had to do with,
but it's linear combination
of symmetry breaking and that.
It's allowed, so it happens
is kind of the bottom line.
But it's allowed
by the symmetries.
OK.
And so finally, this is
the example I'm actually
going to get you to do.
So I'll have you look on the
problem set at the k constants.
And they have an analogous
result to that one.
You'll do the
calculation in SU(3).
And the kind of result that
you should expect to get
is something that
looks like this.
So I'm using this
B0 notation that I
introduced over there just so I
could write it all on one line.
And these mus with
the subscript i
are just some shorthand
for some contributions
coming from loops.
And f is the result in L0.
So f is the parameter
in L0, whereas f pi
is the physical decay
constant of the pion.
So one result which is
encoded in this formula
is that the Lagrangian
parameter is actually
equal to the decay
constant at lowest order
in chiral perturbation theory.
That's something I didn't cover.
I cover it when I teach
quantum field theory three.
You can look at my notes
to see that derivation.
Those of you that have
taken QFT3 from me,
you've already seen that.
And basically, what I'm
asking for in the problem set
is I guide you
with several parts,
but how to think about
these higher order terms.
What are the loop
graph contributions?
How do you get these terms from
the higher order Lagrangians?
How you put it all together?
It's a nice example of this use
of chiral perturbation theory.
And again, we see that
a physical observable,
which is this decay constant,
has a chiral expansion.
And the thing that chiral
perturbation theory is actually
doing is allowing you
to predict both the form
of that expansion, as well
as these things here, which
are chiral logarithms.
So if you ask about predictive
power, the polynomial terms
in terms of higher order
in the quark masses
that are polynomial, you end
up having unknown coefficients.
But the terms with
logarithms have
coefficients which are fixed
by your lower order Lagrangian.
So those are things
that you predict
with the chiral
perturbation theory.
When people do
lattice calculations,
they need to do
chiral extrapolations.
And then they're using
formulas like this one.
OK, so any questions about that?
AUDIENCE: Did the
M pi [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
physical mass.
This is the physical mass.
This is the quark masses.
M0 is just this combination
with M up and M down.
AUDIENCE: So the mu
dependence cancel between--
IAIN STEWART: And
the mu dependence
cancels because these
guys all depend on mu.
Yeah.
And same thing here,
these guys depend on mu.
Here, I have just enough
room to make that explicit.
OK, so that actually
covers all the goals
that we had for chiral
perturbation theory,
though it's a fun topic.
And there's many more
things we could discuss,
but that's what we
needed to discuss.
And so we're going to move on.
So the next thing I
want to talk about
as an example of effective
field theory is heavy
quark effective theory.
So again, what are our goals
with this effective theory?
We will see some new
features showing up
that we haven't seen before.
We will find out what it means
to take a Lagrangian that
has labeled fields.
We'll spend a little
bit of time on symmetry.
Because in this heavy
quark effective theory,
there's actually something
called heavy quark's symmetry,
which is not apparent in
QCD, but becomes apparent
in this theory.
And there's a trick known as
using covariate representations
in order to encode
symmetry predictions.
And it's a very
powerful thing that's
not special to this theory, but
you could use it in general.
And I want to teach it to you.
So that's one thing we'll do.
It's kind of like
a spurion analysis,
but a little bit more powerful.
And finally, anomalous
dimensions that are functions
is something that we'll show
up here, not just numbers.
There's something called
reparameterization invariance,
which you can think of a kind of
symmetry that we'll talk about.
And finally, if that
list is not long enough,
we'll add one more
thing which I hinted at.
So I said, when we
talked about Ms bar,
that it wasn't a perfect
scheme for doing things,
but there were some limitations.
And we'll come, at the
end of this chapter,
to what those limitations are.
The limitations come from
power-like scale separation.
And that's related to
something called renormalons.
So we'll learn what
a renormalon is
and why it has something to
do with the failure of Ms bar
and how one can get
around that failure
and how one actually
needs to get around
that failure in some cases.
OK, so that's the list of goals.
It's kind of, in some ways, in
order of importance, actually.
So when we think about heavy
quark effective theory,
you shouldn't think about
it as just something
that you would need to do if
you wanted to do heavy work
physics because the idea
of what we're doing here
is much more general than that.
The idea of what
we're doing here
is we're saying,
take a heavy particle
and think about what
happens if I tickle it.
And that heavy particle could be
a heavy source to some theory.
We'll talk about it in
the context of them being
heavy quarks, but
you should really
think of it as any
heavy particle tickled
by light particles.
And what we really
mean is that we want
to study the heavy particle.
And since we want to
study it, we better not
remove it from the theory.
So we want to tickle it with
light degrees of freedom
with small momentum
transfer, but we don't want
to integrate that particle out.
So another way of
saying this, if you
don't want to think of
it as a heavy particle,
is that you have some source.
And that source can be
tickled and could wiggle,
but it's sort of mostly
just a static source.
And then it could wiggle.
And that's what this is an
effective field theory for.
So we'll talk about it in
the context of heavy quark
effective theory.
And some of the things,
like heavy quark symmetry,
will be special to that theory.
But more generally, the kind
of approach we're taking
is a more general thing.
So what's heavy quark
effective theory?
So you have a heavy quark.
And you have it sitting in a
bound state, which is a meson.
So that means it's surrounded
by light degrees of freedom,
one heavy quark,
lots of light junk.
In the quark model, you'd say
it's a Q bar q, heavy cork
capital Q and a light cork
little q, like b bar d,
which is the B0.
But that's just a quark
model approximation
for what the degrees
of freedom are.
And there's many more
pairs of Qq bars and gluons
that are really forming
this hydronic state.
So you'd like to be able to make
model independent predictions
for that without having
to worry about the fact
that you're not parameterizing
properly that stuff
that you can't calculate.
And you can do that using
effective field theory.
There's two scales
in the problem.
There's the size of this
thing, the inverse size
of order lambda QCD.
That's the hadronization
that scale.
And that's a scale that's
much less than the quark mass.
So you're really just expanding
in lambda QCD divided by Mq.
That's what this
effective theory will be.
And what you want
to describe are
fluctuations of the heavy
quark due to the light quarks.
So you could think
that this guy is
so heavy he just sits in
the middle of the state,
and he's static.
And then he gets tickled
by the light stuff that's
flying and whizzing around.
And that's a reasonable picture.
So what we really
want to do here
is an example of top-down
effective field theory again.
So going back to our
like integrating out
heavy particles, but now we
want to keep the heavy particles
in the theory, not remove them.
But still, we want to take
a low energy limit of them.
So that means that we have to
take a low energy limit of QCD,
which is id slash
minus Mq Q. And you
can see that part
of the problem here
is that the Mq is
upstairs, which
makes taking the limit
not completely obvious.
In the case where we were
doing the heavy bosons,
we sort of saw that it
was always in propagators.
And we could just think of,
since it's always they're
internal, we just expand.
Here, we want to keep
the Q in the theory.
So we have to really think
about how we take this limit.
So let's start slowly and
consider the propagator
for a heavy quark.
And we'll come back
to the Lagrangian.
And we'll consider it with some
on-shell momentum, which we'll
consider an on-shell
momentum to be parameterized
in the following way.
So if I have an
on-shell momentum,
I'll say that p is equal to
MqV, so that p squared is
equal to Mq squared
and this V is 1.
So once I pull out
the mass dimension Mq,
the remaining thing I call V.
And that's just some parameter
which squares to 1 on-shell.
Now, if I have kicks, which are
from light degrees of freedom,
then I don't have
exactly on-shell.
So P mu is MqV, which is like
on-shell piece plus something
small, k mu.
And k mu is of order lambda QCD.
So this is like saying the
on-shell piece plus the tickle.
And if I want to
construct the propagator,
then the propagator is encoding
the optional off-shellness
of the degree of freedom.
That's 1 over the off-shellness.
So it'll depend on the tickle.
OK, so we could just take QCD
propagator, which is this,
and just plug in that formula.
There's Mq squared, which
cancels this Mq squared.
Then there's some cross-terms
that don't get cancelled.
So there's one that comes from
the dot product of the V dot M
with the k term.
That's this.
And then there's
the k squared term.
So I have these.
And then I can expand that.
M is a positive
quantity, so it doesn't
change the sign of the i0.
And if I expand in M, then the
leading term looks like that.
It's M independent.
And then there's some order
1 over M terms, which I could
also work out what they are.
OK, so that we could expand
even though we don't, a priori,
know how to expand
the Lagrangian.
We could also think about
vertices in this theory.
This is the propagator.
What about vertices?
And again, this is a top-down.
So we can think about
vertices in QCD.
So if this is a
heavy particle here,
we could think about
what would happen.
How do we expand those?
And there doesn't look
like there's really
anything going on here because
there's nothing to expand.
But because these things
are heavy particles here,
you realize from the
propagator formula
here that you're going
to have 1 plus V slashes
on each side of this guy.
So for a propagator
on each side,
you can make a simplification.
And that's because 1
plus V slash over 2 gamma
mu 1 plus V slash over 2,
after some Dirac algebra,
is just V mu times 1
plus V slash over 2.
So the gamma mu becomes a V mu.
So the vertice, once you
take that into account,
is just minus igTA V mu.
Even if we don't think
about starting with the QCD
Lagrangian, if this
is our Feynman rule
and that's our propagator,
we can write down
an effective theory for that
that gives those Feynman rules.
And that actually is
the HQET Lagrangian.
So sorry for going
a little bit over,
but I wanted to at least
get a little bit into this.
OK, so by construction
this way, we
can arrive at this Lagrangian.
And next time, I'll
come back and I'll
show you how you
can really properly
take this limit of
the QCD Lagrangian
to get the same thing.
OK, but that is the HQET.
The lowest order of the
HQET Lagrangian is this.
So it's a linear V
dot D decoupling.
V is a parameter,
and so I've put it
as a parameter on the field.
We'll see more why that
was done next time.
And there's a projection
relation on the field.
If I'm using a
four-component field,
then I have this
projection relation.
I could also read it in
a two-component notation,
and then I wouldn't need that.
But for four-component
notation, you do need that.
We'll talk about
that next time, too.